the united states had its least
bad day in terms of covid yesterday
that it has had in nearly six months
dating all the way back to september of
2020.
now we were worried after seeing a
precipitous decline
starting in mid-january in cases and
deaths and hospitalizations
that it was leveling out and even
averages crept up
for a period of about four or five days
a couple of weeks ago
that has now further reversed and we are
on the way back down
and that is such welcome good news
where for a year there has been very
little good news this is our weekly
covet update
deaths continue down cases continue down
hospitalizations continue down as
vaccinations continue climbing now
averaging more
than 2.1 million vaccinations a day over
the last week let's go through them one
by one
first of all cases remember cases peaked
on a january 11th at an average of 255
000 cases per day
an insane number we are now down
77 to about
58 000 cases a day over the last
week still a long way to go remember dr
fauci says
we can't really think about normality
until we of course have way more people
vaccinated but until cases get below 10
000 cases a day
but being down 77 is a great thing
secondly deaths deaths peaked
uh with an average of about 3 400 deaths
a day
more than a 911 a day in the last few
days of january
deaths are down to a still tragic
1600 per day that is a decline of 53
percent
it's an indicator that things are going
in the right direction
it's hard to feel good about 1600 people
a day dying
and i don't feel good about it but at
least we are down to that number
rather than seeing deaths climb remember
that deaths lag
cases by several weeks so we would hope
that in a few weeks we would be down 77
in deaths the way we are down 77 percent
in cases today
next indicator and this is increasingly
an important indicator
uh debt deaths lag cases by a period of
time
cases also depend on testing
hospitalizations
is a really important indicator to be
looking at as people get vaccinated
hospitalizations
new hospitalizations daily are down
from their peak of about 18 000 people
going into the hospital each day with
covet in mid-january
eighteen thousand was the peak down to
about five thousand a day
lately again hard to feel good about
every day
five thousand people have to go into the
hospital because of covid
but it's a decline of 72 percent that is
huge
and then total cumulative people in the
hospital
at one point we had 125 000 people in
the u.s
hospitalized with covid that is down to
30
000 that's a decline in hospitalizations
of 76
so these are dramatically improving
numbers
that must continue to decline now what
about the variants
i have good news about variants the fear
is
the vaccines won't work against variants
that's been the fear
we have a new england journal of
medicine report
of the three major variants the three
major bearings are what's called the
b117 variant
that's the uk variant the b 1351 variant
that's the south african
variant and then the p1 variant which is
the brazilian
variant a study looked at
neutralization of those variants with
serum from people who have been
vaccinated fully
two pfizer doses and then you wait the
one to two weeks
the data is very good i'm putting up a
complicated image for our video audience
if if it looks confusing don't worry uh
what we are looking at here
are um these three variants i mentioned
plus two subsets of the south african
variant
all of the serum samples so the idea is
you get serum from vaccinated people
the serum has antibodies those
uh serum samples efficiently
neutralized all of the virus variants
that is really good news but let's let's
be cautious
the cautious piece is basically two
things number one
primarily with the south african variant
and secondarily with the brazilian
variant
the level of neutralization is closer to
the minimum necessary to defeat the
virus so what that means is
the vaccines appear to be enough
in most cases to defeat these variants
but it's closer to borderline which
means that in some people
if you don't generate as many antibodies
because
the antibody generation is on a
distribution curve and some people
will be at the lower end of the curve
which can be by chance or due to a
condition
that affects your immune system it will
be more borderline whether the vaccine
will completely protect you from the
south african or brazilian variants
it would be closer to escaping the
vaccine
but in most people you you will not
you will be protected and even if you're
not and most people who
don't get enough protection against
those variants you would get a very mild
mild illness a cold sniffles etc
last sort of caveat these are serum
tests
in labs in the real world with
people you would expect that it would
not be as
open and shut as the data is in these
serum tests but it is still as
reassuring as we would hope
based on the significant doom and gloom
about
the variance escape the vaccine period
does not appear to be true based on
everything we know right now so let's
keep it going
this is not the time to ease up let's
continue to to push for the declines
and we're we're within months of a
significant return
to normalization if we can keep going on
vaccination
and doing what what most states have
been doing
remember march 26th one day
membership blowout we had an
unfortunately
really bad month from the standpoint of
memberships in february
a lot of people still hit with the
economic destruction of the virus having
to cancel their memberships
february being a shorter month not as
many people signing up so we are doing a
one-day membership special
the theme of it will be vaccine related
and it'll be march 26th if you want to
be notified about that special just get
on my mailing list at davidpakman.com
and you will get a a perfect email on
the morning of march 26
telling you how to avail yourself of
this discount and of course let me know
how things are going in your state as
far as vaccinations go
by finding me on twitter deepakman
today's show is sponsored by an
excellent audiobook
called takeover how a conservative
student club
captured the supreme court this is the
latest audiobook from noah feldman it
just came out
and feldman actually narrates the
audiobook himself
noah feldman of course is a harvard law
professor
and constitutional scholar you may
remember him
from his prominent role in trump's
impeachment number one
and the book takeover looks at how the
federalist society became the most
powerful legal organization in the
country six of the nine
current supreme court justices are
current or former members of the
federalist society
and takeover dives into what the
organization is what it stands for its
relationship with american politics
the federalist society is an
organization
anyone in my audience should be aware of
and the audiobook
has a ton of excellent insight into it
and the role it plays
i really enjoyed listening to the
audiobook i think anybody
in my audience would as well so grab
takeover
by noah feldman the audiobook is just
4.99
and you can get it at davidpakman.com
takeover or wherever you buy audiobooks